prosecutors say a Los Angeles man
charged with threatening to kill Boston
Globe reporters had more than a dozen
weapons at home Robert Chain allegedly
made harassing calls to the newspaper
because he was angry that it had
organized an editorial protest against
President Trump in part for attacking
the press court papers say he repeated a
phrase the president uses to criticize
the press Niki batiste is following the
investigation Niki good morning good
morning a law enforcement source tells
CBS News at least 20 guns and hundreds
of rounds of ammunition were found at
robber chains home his alleged threats
come less than two months after five
newspaper employees were shot to death
at the Capitol Gazette in Maryland chain
was released on $50,000 bond yesterday
but he did not go quietly there is no
tree branch in America leaving a Los
Angeles federal court Thursday Robert
Chain refused to answer questions about
the allegations he threatened to kill
Boston Globe journalists but he did have
something he wanted to say yeah I would
like to make one statement America
America was saved when Donald J Trump
was elected president prosecutors say
between approximately August 10th in
August 22nd Jane made around 14
threatening phone calls to the globe
according to court documents in one call
chain said he was going to shoot every
effing one of you in another he
allegedly said as long as you keep
attacking the president I will continue
to threat harass and annoy the Boston
Globe so fake thank you after the globe
asked newspapers across the country to
condemn president Trump's attacks on the
press the response from more than 400
news outlets was published on August
16th I called the fake news the enemy of
the people and they are in a phone call
on August 16th
Chane allegedly told the globe you're
the enemy of the people I'm going to
shoot you in the effing head later today
the president says things like enemies
of the people and then people call the
Boston Globe newsroom repeating those
very words
Alex Kingsbury is a member of the Boston
Globe editorial board how is your
newsroom staff feeling today we're glad
that this particular person has been
been brought to justice and work
committed again recommitted to doing
this important work records show chain
also purchased a new 9-millimeter rifle
in May he is scheduled to appear in
Boston a federal court on September 24th
if convicted he could face up to five
years in jail no the FBI doing a good
job getting him indeed very scary Nikki
thank you